So no cue goes off to meet the coachman
and the coachman has already said he's
collecting bad little boys and he's,
he's,
he's got them on the coach,
they're all delinquent types here.
The ticket on the coach was the ace of
spades,
which is what Pinocchio is holding.
And he's with this character here called
Lamp Wick.
That's an interesting name.
So he's the,
he's the thing that Burns in the middle
of a light lamp wick.
And that's interesting because it's a
play on Lucifer.
Lucifer means bringer of light.
And so lamp wick is a play on that.
And lamb pork is really a nasty piece of
work.
He's got this false arrogance about him.
He's got this like this cynical voice,
really deeply cynical voice and he's
only,
I don't know how old he is supposed to
be in this,
maybe 12 or something like that are 13.
And so he's one of those kids who's,
who's become prematurely cynical.
I'll tell you a story about that.
So I used to live in Montreal.
Um,
I lived in a poor neighborhood.
And uh,
one day I was out in the back alley
building a fence because I was putting
little fence around my back,
my little tiny backyard and there was a
house across the alley down the street,
a ways where there is a lot of,
like not good partying.
Lot of bikers are hanging around there.
And I knew there was a little kid that
lived there as well.
Anyways,
I was out there in the back alley
pounding away on my fence and these
little kids came up and they were
little.
They were like three and four years old.
Hey.
And they spoke a Jew all right.
A kind of a really heavily accented
Quebecois French and so on.
My French isn't good,
so I could hardly understand them,
but they were what they were watching me
hammer and they got a little closer and
they had one,
one kid who was clearly the leader had a
real scowl on his face.
And so they were watching and I kind of
motion to one of them that they could
use the hammer.
And that kid said,
uh,
and I,
I'm gonna mangle this.
But he says you have olay or something
like that.
And what it meant is I'll steal that.
And so I thought,
you know,
and then he came over and he tugged on
it and he wanted me to take it and he
was quite angry and while I wasn't gonna
let them take it.
And then so,
so I couldn't engage them.
I couldn't get him to play,
you know,
and his buddies were sort of hanging
around behind him and they wouldn't come
and play because he wouldn't.
So he was hostile right away to me.
And then so the finance piece was laying
out in the La and these little monsters
started running across it,
which I thought was really remarkable,
you know.
But it was terrible at the same time
because they were really little kids
that shouldn't be happening when you're
like three or four if that's happening
at that age,
things are not good.
And so that kid was already like,
seriously not happy with the world.
And you know,
I'd been studying antisocial behavior
for a long time by that point.
And I knew that the kids who are
destined to jail later in their lives,
our kids who are rough and tough when
they're two years old but then don't
get,
or maybe worse,
they get anti socialized,
which is exactly what happened to this
kid.
He'd obviously been ignored and abused.
I'm certainly no one had ever played
with them in any real way because he,
he wouldn't play.
And it's not good if a kid is that
little and you can't get them to play,
something's gone seriously wrong because
they're so playful at that age that
like,
it's like 90 percent of them.
Anyway.
So they were running back and forth on
this fence.
I thought it stomping on it,
you know?
And I was right there.
I thought,
well,
I.
First of all,
I thought that was remarkable,
but I also thought it was absolutely
horrifying because,
you know,
in some sense I could see where this kid
was headed and why at that early stage
in his life,
it's really,
it's not a pleasant thing to behold,
you know,
but there was nothing that could be done
about it.
And that's kind of what this lamp wick
is like.
He's prematurely cynical.
This kid was already cynical and he was
like four years old,
you know,
most kids don't get cynical till they're
teenagers,
you know?
And then often they don't get completely
cynical and usually they more or less
grow out of it.
But he had.
It happened him much earlier.
So this lamp,
what character he'd already,
he's already decided that he knows
everything that everyone else is.
His opinion is worth nothing and that
there's nothing in culture society that
holds any use utility whatsoever for
someone like him.
Now you can imagine developing that way
if you were raised in a family where
people were generally generally lying to
you and that they randomly treated you
or neglected you and that you couldn't
discern anything about them that was
admirable or positive,
you know,
of course you'd assume that the whole
structure is corrupt and that you had to
take care of yourself and no one else
will not.
Of course not everyone assumes that
under those situations,
I shouldn't say of course,
but it's a.
But it's a logical set of conclusions.
So.
And of course it's proportionate to some
degree to how much abuse you take.
Although there are lots of stories of
people who've been terribly abused as
children who grew up to be,
you know,
kind,
remarkable,
responsible,
thoughtful people who were absolutely
opposed to abuse instead of propagating
it.
There's no direct causal pathway.